مرحبا بالجميع مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في كل
مكان ومتابعين عبر المنصات
وبالزمن هنا في الدوحه في هذه الوقفه التي
نطالب فيها بالعداله بعد استشهاد الزميل
سامر ابو دقه واستهدافه برفقه الزميل وائل
الدحدوح الزميل سامر الذي استشهد بعد عمل
طويل
مع شبكه الجزيره ومع ابناء شعبه في قطاع
غزه الذي كان يواصل في هذه الحرب التي
نتابعها مباشره على الشاشات الليل بالنهار
من اجل نقل هذه الصوره الصوره التي
استهدفت والحقيقه التي يحاول الاحتلال
قصفها وتغييب فكان في هذا الاستهداف قتل
للصوره وقتل لناقل هذه الصوره كنا تابعنا
على مدار الايام الماض ضيه ما جرى مع
الزميل سامر وكذلك مع باقي زملائنا في
الميدان الصحفيين الزملاء في الجزيره
وباقي
زملاء الصحفيين العاملين في قطاع غزه وهم
يتركون وحدهم ليغطوا وينقلوا هذه الحقيقه
التي تستهدف ويراد لها ان تغيب وهذه الحرب
حرب الاباده على الشعب الفلسطيني
التي تحاول تحاول قوات الاحتلال تغييبها
وان تشن ها بصمت ودون ما اي مشاركه من اي
صحافه او صحفيين دوليين وكنا نتابع ما جرى
على الهواء مباشره من قتل للزميل سامر
ومنع لطواقم الاسعاف من الوصول اليه
واستشهاد طواقم الدفاع المدني الذين
حاولوا الوصول اليه ونجاه زميلنا وائل
الدحدوح بمعجزه من هذا
الاستهداف المباشر نترحم عليه وعلى كل
شهداء الجزيره في هذا اليوم و تمنى
السلامه لباقي الزملاء الذين اصيبوا سواء
في هذه الحادثه او في حوادث اخرى الزميله
كارمن ومصورها ايضا بنفس النيران في جنوب
لبنان
والعزاء والسلوان والسؤال لله عز وجل بان
يلهم باقي الزملاء الصبره والسلوان على ما
فقدوا الزميل مؤمن شرافي
22 شهيدا من عائلته منهم ابوه وامه واخوته
كذلك الزميل محمد ابو القمصان 19 فردا من
افراد عائلته ايضا منهم ابوه ومجموعه من
اخوته وباقي الزملاء الذين ما زالوا
يعانون في هذه الحرب هم وعائلاتهم ولم
يتخلوا عن نقل الحقيقه لانهم يعلمون جيدا
المسؤوليه التي تقع على عاتقهم وهذه الصور
التي ترسل الى العالم اجمع تكشف فيها هذه
الجرائم على عاتقهم وهذه المسؤوليه التي
يفتخرون
بها ولا نقول عنهم ذلك يقول عنهم ابناء
شعبهم ويفتخرون بهم ابناء شعبهم في
مواصلتهم منهم من
حاول البقاء على مدار الساعه مراقبا
ومتابعا
وناقلا ومنهم من كانت امامه الفرص ان
يغادر ان يرتاح ان يترك هذه المعركه لكنه
اصر ان يتحمل هذه المسؤوليه منهم من يحمل
اقامات خارجيه ومنهم من يحمل جوازات سف
خارجيه ومنهم من طلب منه الاجلاء ولكنهم
ونعلمهم بالاسماء اصروا ان يتحملوا هذه
المسؤوليه ومنهم زميلنا سامر الذي نقف
اليوم مطالبين بالعداله له ولكل الزملاء
الذين فقدوا احباء وما زالوا يتعرضون لخطر
الاستهداف ولخط
الاغتيال ضمن هذه الحرب التي اليوم نتحدث
عنها الحرب على الصوره والحرب على الروايه
والحرب على الحقيقه نبدا هذه الوقفه كلمه
الاستاذ سامي الحاج وهو مدير مركز الجزيره
للحريات وحقوق
الانسان كل عبارات العزاء لا تعبر عن
حزننا العميق نحن وكل الزملاء بشبكه
الجزيره على رحيل الشهيد سامر شهيد
الصحافه بغزه العزه الذي مضى الى ربه وهو
يؤدي رسالته الانسانيه وفي مهمه انسانيه
ورغم مراره الالم والفراق على فقده الا
انه ارتقى الى ربه نحسبه شهيدا وهذا هو
عزاؤنا لقد فقدنا خلال عقدين 13 من
الزملاء الصحفيين في غزه فقد فقدنا زملاء
فقد زملاء ابائهم وابنائهم واحفادهم في
محاوله من جيش الاحتلال لارهاب واسكات
اصواتهم كل ذلك يحدث في الوقت الذي يحيي
فيه العالم ذكرى مرور
75 عاما على الاعلان العالمي لحقوق
الانسان وما زالت قضايا حمايه الصحفيين
وسلامتهم باعتبارهم شهود الحقيقه تتعرض
للازدراء وعلى ضوء المخاطر غير المسبوقه
التي يواجهها الصحفيون بسبب الغرات الجويه
والهجمات الاسرائيليه على الصحفيين في غزه
فاننا نسعى مع شركائنا في المنظمات
الحقوقيه المعنيه بحقوق الانسان وبسلامه
الصحفين الى اتخاذ اجراءات عاجله لضمان
سلامه الصحفيين وتذكير الدول بالتزاماتها
في تعزيز حريه الصحافه وحمايه الصحفيين
وسلامتهم وسنسعى جاهدين مع شركائنا
باللجوء الى الاليات العداله على المستوى
الدولي والاقليمي والعمل على تقويه تمكين
حاله التضامن بين المنظمات الحقوقيه
والانسانيه الفاعله والمدافعين عن حريه و
وسائل الاعلام وسلامه الصحفيين اضافه الى
حشد وتعبيه الجهود بما يكفل سلامه
الصحفيين وحمايتهم لابد ان تتكاتف وسائل
الاعلام ويتكاتفان
كافراد للتضامن مع بعضهم البعض من خلال
حشد الجهود لتقليل المخاطر عبر الالتزام
بارشادات الامن والسلامه في البيئات
الخطره وتقويه ومسانده حملات المطالبه
بالعداله للضحايا وضمان المساءله لمرتكبي
الجرائم ضدهم ومنعهم من الافلات من العقاب
ختاما اجدد عزائي لاسره الشهيد سامر
ولزملائه بفلسطين وبشبه الجزيره
ونعاه
باننا سنبذل جهودنا بمركز الجزيره للحريات
العامه بالتنسيق مع الشبكه بشان ملاحقه
قتلته لن تتوقف حتى يتم تقديمهم للعداله
الصحافه ليست جريمه الجريمه الجريمه هي
قتل
الصحفيين الصحافه اذا ليست جريمه وهذا
النداء الذي لن نتوقف عن ترديده والمطالبه
بتحقيق العداله لكل الضحايا ومنهم
الصحفيون اذا شكرا استاذ سامي الحاج وايضا
نجدد الترحاب بكل من يقف معنا هنا في هذه
الوقفه ومنهم عائله الزمير سامر ابو دقه
زوجته وابنائه وابنته مرحبا بهم جميعا هنا
بين اهله وانتقل لوائل الدحدوح في غزه
ولزملائه جميعا تحيه وائل هنا من غزه
المحاصره
والمحاربه من كل الاتجاهات من البر والبحر
ومن الارض
نحييكم
ونشد على اياديكم ونحن في هذه اللحظه
الانسانيه هذه اللحظه
الاستثنائيه التاريخيه الفارقه
والحاسم التي يمر بها قطاع غزه وتمر بها
الناس هنا في قطاع غزه
حقيقه لا ندري ماذا يمكن ان نقول في حضره
الموت والشهاده في حضره الدم نازف الذي
يرفض ويابى ان
يتوقف لا ندري باي الكلمات نتسلح واي
العبارات نم تشق في هذه المناسبه الجليله
وفي هذه المناسبه الموجعه
والمحنه ماذا يمكن ان نقول في حضره دماء
الشهيد الزميل الحبيب
المصور سامر ابو دقه الذي ما زالت دماؤه
حاضره ودرعه الصحفي الذي استشهد
فيه حاضرا معنا هنا في هذه الوقفه
الاحتجاجيه احتجاجا على اغتياله لا ندري
ماذا يمكن ان يقال في حضره الفقد والامه
فقد الاحبه والغوالي ماذا يمكن ان نقول في
حضره كل ما يجري في قطاع غزه صحيح
ان هذا الموقف ربما صعب وغير مسبوق ومؤلم
وموجع بطبيعه الحال لكن كان واضحا ان هذا
الالم يراد له ان يسكت الصحفيين وان يقتل
الصوره وان يوقف هذه المسيره ان ربما ان
يصيب بالشلل صاحبه الجلاله وهذه الرساله
الانسانيه تقتل وتد في مهدها هنا في في
قطاع غزه لكن ربما هذا هذا ال هذا الامر
كله بالفعل اصابنا جميعا اصاب كل واحد منا
من الزملاء الذين الان يشاركون هذه الوقفه
الاحتجاجيه اصابهم
بالم لا حدود له وحزن لا حدود له ولكنهم
ايضا ربما من يواسينا ومن يسلينا في هذه
الخطوب والاهوال بالتاكيد انهم جميعا
تماما
كاسره قناه الجزيره من زملاء سامر انهم
جميعا استمروا على درب سامر الصوره استمرت
والصوت ارتفع وا المسيره الصحفيه
والاعلاميه استمرت تماما كما هو الحال بعد
ان غيب الرصاص لنفس القاتل زميلتنا
الجليله شيرين ابو عاقله قبل نحو عامين
ونصف المسيره استمرت ونحن استمرينا من
بعدها اليوم كما
تشاهدون نحن نستمر بالصوت والصوره والكلمه
وبكل اشكال ا يعني المهنه واشكال الحقيقه
ونحن بالتاكيد ان كان هناك من وعد ان كان
هناك من موقف ان كان هناك من كلمه يمكن ان
تخرج من افواهنا جميعا جميعا ومن حناجرنا
جميعا فهي اننا مستمرون مستمرون مستمرون
ما بقيت هذه الاحداث في قطاع غزه وما بقي
فينا عرق ينبض وما دمنا على قيد الحياه ان
لم يكن وقوفا فجلسا او نياما حتى ياذن
الله فينا امرا كان مفعولا بطريقه بطبيعه
الحال بطبيعه الحال ما يحدث في قطاع غز
غزه هو
جريمه ربما ضرب من ضروب الجنون كما يصفها
الجميع حتى الان حسب
الاحصائيات التي صدرت نحو 100 من الصحفيين
والمصورين الفلسطينيين استشهدوا بنفس
القصف وبنفس الرصاص وبنفس الشظايا وكل ذلك
على مرا ومسمع من كل العالم الذي يدعي
زيفا الديمقراطيه وحريه الراي والتعبير
اما في حرب فيتنام التي استمرت نحو 20 عام
لم يسقط سوى اقل من 60 صحفي في 20 عام في
شهرين ونصف سقط 100 صحفي فلسطيني ولم يحرك
العالم ساكنا وربما بعض التصريحات تتحدث
عن انه لا يوجد استهداف للصحفيين هذا امر
يعني يجب ان يوضع تحته الف علامه استفهام
بالتاكيد نحن نه نتوجع اكثر عندما نستمع
الى هذه التصريحات والتلميحات من العالم
الذي يدعي الديمقرا الراي والتعبير ولكن
هذا الالم وهذا الوجع بالتاكيد سوف يتحول
الى حافز اضافي وقوه دفع اضافيه بالنسبه
لنا جميعا ونحن اسمحوا لي ان اتحدث بكل
بلسان كل الزملاء ليس فقط في اسره قناه
الجزيره وانما بلسان كل الحاضرين هنا
والذين لم يحضروا اوهم الحظ في الحضور
للاحتجاج على على على قتل واغتيال الزميل
الحبيب سامر ابو دقه الصوره وربما
الصوت يتقطع وهي الظروف التي نعلمها جميعا
في غزه بفعل انقطاع
الاتصالات المستمر ومحاوله التشويش
المستمر على على الصوره لا نعلم نواسك
نتمنى لك السلامه طبعا نستمد منك العزم في
كل لحظه وانت الذي
تقول سنستمر في تحمل هذه المسؤوليه وفي
نقل الصوره طالما اننا نستطيع ان نقف امام
الكاميرا او حتى نجلس وليد العمري الان من
رام الله اليك
الكلمه التحيه لكم جميعا والرحمه للشهداء
جميعا والرحمه لشهداء شبكه الجزيره
والرحمه للشهيد الغالي الزميل سامر ابو
دقه وشهيده الغاليه شيرين ابو عاقلي ونحن
نقف هنا في مكتب شبكه الجزيره في شارع
شيرين ابو عاقله وسط مدينه رام الله نبكي
زميلنا الغالي المصور الشهيد سامر ابو دقه
ونسال الله الشفاء العاجل لزميلنا العزي
وائل الدحدوح والحمايه والسلامه لباقي
زملائنا في غزه وزملائنا الصحفيين في كل
مكان ونتذكر زميلتنا العزيزه الشهيده
شيرين ابو عاقلي نقف هنا لنتحد بان لا نكل
ولا نمل حتى نحقق لهم العدل
فالعدالة او صحفيات في شبكه الجزيره او
الصحفيين الفلسطينيين بشكل عام الذين
استشهد منهم قرابه ماء في هذه الحرب
الاسرائيليه المدمره الداميه التي اندلعت
في السابع من شهر اكتوبر الماضي وعندما
نطالب بالعداله لسامر وشيرين وجميع
الصحفيين الذين استشهدوا بنيران قوات
الاحتلال والجيش الاسرائيلي سواء في غزه
او بالضفه الغ الغربيه انما نطالب
بالعداله والعدل كي لا تفقد الاجيال
الفلسطينيه المقبله ايمانها بحقها
وبالعدالة الله والقدس على ما يبذلوه من
جهد مميز ومضاعف لنقل الحقيقه الى هذا
العالم
واثمن وقوف زملائنا الصحفيين في غزه
والضفه الغربيه معنا في هذه المحنه
القاسيه المؤلمه التي تسببها هذه الحرب
الداميه التي لم تستهدف الصحفيين وحسب
وانما طالت عائلاتهم ايضا تغمد الله
الجميع بواسع رحمته
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته شكرا
وليد العمر